with the ever increasing demand for food
Engineers have been diligently
researching and introducing Innovative
agricultural Machinery to officially
cater to these needs
these machines are revolutionizing the
way farming is done
and I will now describe and discuss some
of them
what does it look like and how do they
work right now hyper TV will take you to
see and experience them
if you find our machines interesting
please like And subscribe to continue
following our next videos
first let's take a look at the John
Deere 9500i combined Harvester and the
Massey Ferguson truck working together
harmoniously to harvest grass
[Music]
the John Deere 9500i expertly cuts the
grass and transports it into the
threshing and corn Harvester compartment
using a blower too
this powerful machine can handle a
variety of crops such as wheat soybeans
rice corn grass straw and many others
moving on to another remarkable machine
the John Deere 8600i is a specialized
Harvester design with a robust engine
boasting up to 625 horsepower thanks to
its diesel engine
[Music]
equipped with an automatic steering and
wheel lock system this Harvester
provides ease of control while its small
turning radius enables smooth movement
in tight spaces
[Music]
it can Harvest around 300 to 400 tons of
grass per hour depending on various
factors like weather conditions and
grass characteristics ensuring high
performance and saving considerable time
and effort
foreign
[Music]
fiber the closerian 4000 is specifically
designed
this machine features a powerful Mandy
2676 lu62 engine with a cylinder
capacity of 12.4 liters
the harvesting process involves cutting
the hemp stems with cutting blades and
then redirecting them into the machine
for further processing
inside the machine screens separate the
leaves and branches from the hemp vessel
fibers which are collected and bundled
for subsequent processing
it offers exceptional efficiency
harvesting around 8 to 14 tons of hemp
vessel fiber per hectare of land
surpassing traditional machines in terms
of productivity
now let's explore the Aven 745 A
specialized device manufactured by
Optimal that excels in cutting moving
and transplanting trees
this machine utilizes a cut Lan system
and a tree spade machine to safely and
officially remove trees from the ground
it can handle trees with diameters
ranging from 20 to 60 centimeters and
trunk Heights from 60 to 240 centimeters
[Music]
moreover the Aven 745 supports tree
transplantation allowing for quick and
precise repositioning all while
preserving the root system and growth
potential of the plants
[Music]
moving on to Apple harvesting cider
production in the northern region of
France relies on a machine specially
designed to shake wreck apples from the
trees
this machine clamps the apple tree trunk
securely and utilizes a vibrating
mechanism with a frequency ranging from
10 to 30 Hertz ensuring that the ripe
apples fall without causing damage to
the trees
[Music]
the vibration level can be adjusted
according to the type of fruit providing
versatility and efficiency in the
harvesting process
[Music]
thank you
additionally a concentrically using
structured Apple Harvester is used to
gather apples that have fallen on the
ground
this machine employs fan blades and a
conveyor belt to swiftly and efficiently
collect scattered apples while
minimizing impact and maintaining fruit
quality
in the Netherlands beans are a crucial
crop and the highly regarded plager epd
Bean Harvester plays a significant role
in their Harvest
[Music]
this machine operates continuously
optimizing productivity by harvesting
1.5 to 3 tons of beans per hour
[Music]
with Advanced features and automation
capabilities it enables quick and
efficient harvesting reducing waste and
costs for farmers
care harvesting is made easier with the
fence 720 an advanced and efficient
harvesting machine
it is equipped with a modern Mandy 836
engine offering a maximum power output
of 200 horsepower along with smart
harvesting mechanisms and improved
features
the fence 720 can Harvest around 8 to 10
tons per day depending on the type of
crop
[Music]
to assist farmers in harvesting oranges
and orange Harvester machine has been
developed
this machine offers six standing
positions and facilitates the harvesting
of oranges even from Heights of
approximately three meters
[Music]
it ensures convenience and speed as it
allows individuals to harvest oranges
from any position without the need for
extensive movement
in China sugarcane cultivation involves
spreading straw on planting ridges to
keep the sugar cane moist during rinsing
[Music]
a simple machine is utilized for this
purpose spreading straw on three ridges
simultaneously providing a
cost-effective and efficient solution
thank you
for Rice cultivation the case ihyh 9240
is a high-end axial flow rice combined
Harvester
powered by a 16.16 liter cursor 16
diesel engine it boasts a maximum power
output of up to 634 horsepower
the Pro-Drive automatic steering system
and intelligent control system simplify
operation increasing harvesting
efficiency
the combination of an independent
classification system and the acute
guide automatic steering system ensures
cleanliness and accuracy during the
Harvest ultimately delivering the best
quality rice
[Music]
with a width of 8 meters this Harvester
significantly boosts productivity
allowing Farmers to cover more ground
efficiently
the grass baling machine has simplified
the process of harvesting and preserving
grass
equipped with a 50 kilowatt case 130
pulling head in a grass baling mechanism
this machine creates rectangular Bales
each approximately 50 cm long
its compact design allows for easy
collection and storage of grass
for land cultivation the John Deere
8360r tractor and lemkin Daimon 12 plow
said work in Perfect Harmony
[Music]
the lemkin diamond plow set with its 12
large plow blades and adjustable depth
of up to 30 cm ensures deep and Powerful
digging and tilling effectively removing
plant debris excess materials and hard
soil clumps
[Music]
with a width of up to 3.5 meters per
plowing this machine enables quick and
efficient cultivation of large fields
lastly the sugar beet harvesting machine
features large Wheels in a powerful
engine allowing it to maneuver flexibly
on various terrains
it cuts the grass around the rows of
beets using controllers to cut and
bundle the Beats together
this machine saves time and effort for
workers while increasing productivity
and harvest quality
with ongoing technological advancements
sugar beet harvesting machines continue
to be upgraded and improved to meet the
needs of farmers
[Music]
these remarkable agricultural machines
play a vital role in providing Global
Food security
by improving efficiency reducing waste
and increasing productivity they
contribute to the sustainable growth of
the agricultural industry
if you find these machines fascinating
please like And subscribe to our channel
to stay updated on our future videos
thank you for joining us on this journey
of exploring the world of agricultural
machinery
foreign
[Music]